tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
mirabolante video sul mio canale siamo
sunghe oh my name is questo gioco di
oggi la musica è tutto dire ho solo
visto che tu lavori a ok performance
matter va bene non mangiati le penne
questo c'è scritto sul muro di lavoro va
beh io sono al lavoro va bene ok
devo fare e posso prendere il caffè
posso no non lo prendo che va bene
queste for guys solo prima questa era la
beta di paul guys non mangiarti le penne
non era il mio obiettivo allora andiamo
avanti
cosa devo fare qua chi meriti you're
fired sei licenziato bene importante noi
dice non facciamoci senza nel mio primo
giorno ragazzi non posso spingere questo
sì ciao ragazzi come è andata la
giornata via adesso vado al mio posto è
fatto è fatto
devo qualcuno ha dimenticato il coatch è
una carta mi scusi dovete fare un giro
io sul mio carrello posso portare
persone o dio dio dio fa niente a 1 il
capo salve lo metto a posto questo è per
me anzi web dispetti che lo prendo
eccolo no io vorrei prec
vorrei non riesco a raccogliere le robe
la terra mi scusi signor capo è per
questo che cosa devo fare io qua pensa
questo che si è visto tizio ubriachi
signor cannes
non so come si sta in piedi non sta più
pieni vabbè mi trascinerò al mio posto
di lavoro non so dove sia ma ok perfetto
posso entrare in una casa dal nola
rimetto a posto lei continui a lavorare
non ho capito qual è il mio posto di
lavoro
non ho capito posso sedermi qua vi dò
fastidio
vorrei lavorare però non so il tasto per
sedermi lavoro in piedi lavori piedi
questo e come molto i miei video io
c'ero testata sera eccoci qua ho
lavorato
stavo lavora stavo prendendo punti
lavoro o la performance metterà anche
che stanno davanti alla così fa più la
work va bene con tutte e due le mani si
che lavori meglio
ok ok yes yes yes punti works è fattore
guarda proprio futuro come un milanese
quadro perfetto di milano dai e via ok
mi si mi è entrato un braccio nella
tastiera non so se è normale ma chi se
ne frega continuiamo a fatturare braccia
alle tastiere non ci fermeranno
ora la performance come va verde il mio
capo è contentissimo secondo a vederlo
sono convinto
guarda come fattore guarda guarda più
punti work regalo la performance quasi
totale adesso chiamo web donne sei stato
pro mostro va bene proprio va bene
quindi per uscire ma no ma mi ha fatto
uscire proprio no volevo giocare allora
riempio il caffè ragazzi ma non si
riempi è quello il problema
l'ho messo sotto io vado si riempie di
sotto nei sopranos si riempie mai grab
del velo performed elevator e bring it
ok
devo prendere questo e portarlo al
lavoratore numero 8 che sta 2 cacchio
sta che ne so io ti togli dalle palle
chi sei tu togliti marizio né no non ci
credo 16 messo in mezzo dove sta all 82
sta all 8 non c'è lo fa perché non sono
riuscito anche a entrare quindi i due
ragazzi non si può fare ciò è
impossibile è impossibile portare il
caffè al capo va bene ce l'avevo prima
potevo ottenere quello in mano anna ciao
aspetta prima una tazza nota ciao ci
posso provare stavolte l'unica volta in
cui ci posso provare
ok ok il cappello messo cioè l'avete
visto tutti entrato il caffè entrato se
poi non rimane dentro perché non hanno
programmato che può star dentro perché
io l'ho messo e non è che non lo mesi
arrivo pieni ecco lo fa ma l'ho fatto ma
l'ho fatto l'ho portato l'ho portato
gliela preso non so come sia possibile
ma gli ha preso ho portato provato a
portare sta roba alde scotto mano la
porta per superare solo la scatola
portato alla scattate uguale scotto
quale cacchio è sfondato tutto sfondando
tutto fratelli vede devo capire dov'è il
desco 82 cacchio sto desk maledetto che
sono anche i numeri non sono
consequenziali 26 ma non sono
consequenziali non lo so non c'è 73 chi
è questo non lo trovo non c'è il 73
maneggiano almeno cammina almeno sta in
piedi santo iddio che 72 lì lo vedo a
sinistra nel 73 non lo vedo 73
cos'è che vuoi è la sky non farò ma in
tempo però che lo posso portare lo
stesso anche se hanno fatto in tempo per
favore
ok eccolo eccolo eccolo ecco cielo equa
eccoti qua a posto te l'ho portato la
fai a camminare e porca [ __ ] devo
portare il caffè al capo il caffè al
campo veloce caffè non farò mai tempo ad
arrivare libri mai mai però a portargli
una tazza vuota dato non si può riempire
non riesco neanche ad afferrare la tazza
figuriamoci che spreca e speranza avrei
di riempirla l'ho presa ti prego non
core
te lo do lo stesso tieni è qua e qua e
quando mi ha kiesto rivoli fa la stessa
cosa e qua tiene e tenga a lei e questo
glielo portata
glielo portata motion la guarda viene
portata beh va beh va beh ma va da bere
e suo tema bevo il caffè
beh ma questo caffè si tiri su posso
fare il mio lavoro adesso no sulla sua
tastiera magari è bello stare in un
ambiente lavoro santa
comunque portante quello al giorno
d'oggi i lavori sono tutti un po un
catino no quindi l'ambiente sano posso
entrare dentro l'ascensore non lo so
sarebbe fico ha forse l'ho portata
ve lo devo portare questo e questo tuo
in velotto quello che mai che sto prima
che non ho capito forse era questo non
lo comprende il dubbio io vi ho portato
un po tutto va bene spero che vada bene
queste guarda guarda ho portato tutto
quello che c'è nel dell'ufficio quindi
una di queste cose sarà anche perché non
solo inglese ma immagino ecco qua ho
portato anche questo non so se le serve
però un po di roba celso hamas scelga
lei quale di queste lebel o perché non
capisco cosa voglia dire quindi perfetto
ho portato un po tutto il campo ha
bisogno del caffè secondo il capo ha
bisogno di un ambulanza non del caffè
però vabbè campo tutto a posto
da qua il caffè e gli ho portato prima
niente meno 25 per cento aveni rimango
sulla sua scrivania così sa qualcosa in
contrario va bene signore signori
durante un valzer primarie basta
prendere il caffè capo veramente
facciamo questo valzer un ballo tutti
insieme spero che questa giornata di
lavoro chi sia piaciuta e mi sono
particolarmente divertito a girare per
l'ufficio insomma un gioco è un gioco
simpa è un gioco che insomma è
realistico e rarissimo vedere però
evidenzia 900 ragazzi questa è la mia
giornata di lavoro tipica tipica
agricola di portare sempre il caffè il
capo e quando non sapete cosa chiede una
persona piuttosto di dire non ho capito
portatele un po tutto cosa cioè vorrà
alla fine vita
ora vi sia piaciuto ragazzi questa
situazione stia del canale è presentato
mi piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]